everybody and welcome to another python
3 tutorial video in this video we're
going to be doing is combining two of
our standard library modules and using
them to parse a website so we're going
to be using url lib and
re for regular expression
so with that let's go ahead and get
started so we're gonna need to import uh
url
lib.request and we're also gonna import
url lib uh dot parse
finally we're going to import our e for
regular expressions and we're ready to
go so first we're going to define our
url that we want to visit uh let's go
ahead and visit http colon slash
pythonprogramming.net
next uh we're going to say our values uh
so we're going to do a search on
pythonprogramming.net so our values
whoops dictionary is
s
will be equal to
space socks
basics
and then we'll say submit
colon
search
okay
so those are the values that we're going
to parse in and uh
post
now we're going to say data
equals urllib.parse.urlncode
and we're going to encode values
i'm going to say data equals data
dot
and code
utf-8
oops
and then we're going to say rec for
request equals urllib.request.request
capital r
and we're going to make the request of
url passing through data
and then the response will be
urllib.request.urlopen
request
just as a quick aside i'm not really
explaining any of this stuff that we're
typing because we've already covered the
url lib tutorial so if you feel lost
here like if you're starting on this
video or something and you don't know
why i'm doing what i'm doing uh check
out the url lib tutorials
for python 3.
so response now
uh resp data for response data equals
rest.read
and then
uh what we want to do is we're going to
use regular expressions so if you
remember last time what this printed out
we could say print uh
rest data so we can save and run that
let's make sure that works first i
suppose anyway so we get all this junk
right
um but within this junk there's some
normal stuff um we don't really see
anything here uh at least so far for me
i don't really see it but here we go
here we've got some math basics blah
blah blah
here's a paragraph tag finally anyway so
here's a paragraph um i'm not seeing the
opening paragraph tag but you'll have to
take my word for it there's an opening
paragraph tag somewhere anyway the idea
is we want to parse out paragraph data
so
generally in html people have you know
header one header two for like big
titles and then or maybe even header
three
then maybe subtitles had a three header
four maybe header two
and then
the content is almost always a paragraph
tag just a you know
your typical like this uh
let's make some space
you know you've got a paragraph tag like
that then you've got content content
content blah blah blah
and then you have a closing paragraph
tag now depending on the site sometimes
this might be slightly different but
usually it's paragraph tag of some sort
you just might have to parse like this
or something
anyway moving on
so that's what we want so we want to use
a regular expression that's going to say
hey i want to parse everything between
paragraph tags
so what we're going to say is paragraphs
equals
read.findall
and what we're going to do is regular
expression
and the regular expression we want is
it's going to be paragraph tag so like i
said if you want to search for specific
text you would you can just type in that
specific text and so so far we're not
using any special characters so we don't
need to escape anything
and then
parentheses i can't blanket on the name
there
uh this is where the pattern that we
want so like if you want to put let's
see we'll put the closing paragraph so
basically we're saying paragraph tag
paragraph tag will be here and then here
is what you want to search for so you
put between these little curly braces or
curly braces parentheses
and put between these what what data do
we actually want to search for so like
what is the data we want to output
because so far we're saying nothing and
but it's like find something between
paragraph tags but we have to specify
what that something might be
now
my little favorite combination to look
for just anything is a period asterisk
question mark okay so that basically
means find me everything between
paragraph tags and so if we look back at
what these characters actually mean the
period
is
uh basically the period is going to say
any character
right
except for your new line the asterisk is
zero or more repetitions so if there's
zero that's okay and then anything more
than that that's fine and then so we're
basically that this applies to your
period and then finally the question
mark which is match
um
zero or one repetitions so it's
basically finding anything between
paragraph tags and then only one zero or
one repetitions of that and then it will
break because that's the end of your
paragraph and then continue on so i just
always like when i'm parsing websites
sometimes it's not between paragraph
tags it might be between something else
but though the combination of regular
expressions that i will use is always a
period asterisk question mark just
because it works so well
so
what we'll do now is we'll say
um
for each
p
in paragraphs
print
each p
okay so let's save and run that and see
what we get
and it's going to take a second to pop
up there it is
oh man i think we were printing source
code there hold on
yeah we printed the response data let's
go ahead and comment that out we don't
want to do that anymore so let's try
that one more time
oh
we didn't put okay so paragraphs read
out find all
the great regular expression but what
are we looking in to here and we're
looking for it in resp uh data you need
to convert this to a string uh because
it's not uh in string but anyways try it
one more time
and now we get this right so this is all
of our
paragraph data okay
so that's going to conclude the tutorial
of using url lib and regular expressions
uh to parse the website if you guys have
any questions or comments on this feel
free to leave them below as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions and until next
time